Youth Change I'll
regenerate it now
If you don't have a shield, I can destroy it as many times as I want with my magic
[Music] I
made time for it Anyway,
Eingrendel,
right? I'm sorry, but my disciple will win.
Until now, I've been teaching you how to use this.  It seems like I was too distracted by the government to be able to
move around properly,
but now that I have prey in a familiar shape, I
can concentrate all my attention on evasion.Are
you satisfied with that?Let's enjoy it more properly.
Hurry up and start a fight between me and you. I'm not
interested in this battle. I
just want to save Yuna from the beginning.
[Music] [
Applause]
[Music]